with Captain marbles for at least right
around the corner lucky fans who've
gotten to see early screenings of the
film have been discussing elements of
the movie online whilst reddit currently
has a full plot breakdown on this site I
thought I'd discuss probably the two
aspects of the film the MCU fans are
most excited for those being the
post-credits scenes of the film
throughout this video I'll be breaking
down all of the leaked information we
have on those scenes and whilst they
haven't been confirmed officially this
information is usually correct as was
with my spider-verse
and Ant Man in the wasp leaked videos
there will of course be heavy spoilers
here so if you don't want to know
anything about either scenes then I
highly suggest that you turn off now
without the way I'm definition and
welcome to the channel where I ruin it
so you don't have to the first thing to
know about the end of Captain Marvel is
that we get to post-credit scenes with
one happening after the initial titles
and the other coming after all credits
are old the first credits scene involves
Captain Marvel showing up to Avengers HQ
after the events of infinity war to
encounter Black Widow and Captain
America Captain America and Black Widow
have managed to get Nick Fury's page yet
but they are both unsure of exactly what
the signal on it means Captain Marvel n
steps forward saying that she's here to
answer the call and asks where Nick Fury
is the scene is reportedly very similar
to the one in the Avengers end game
trailer this is very likely a scene that
was filmed for endgame and will be
pulled directly from that movie similar
to how civil war was in the post-credits
scene of ant-man the second post-credit
scene involves goosed the cat coughing
up the Cosmic Cube or the tesseract as
it would later come to be known in the
Avengers this confirms that the
tesseract is in shields possession which
we all know was hinted at from the
ending of Captain America at the First
Avenger scene to confirms that goose
isn't from Earth and it's more of a liar
note to end the film on that neatly ties
together some of the film's elements
into the great
universe obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on this leaked information and
whether you are hyped to see the movie
when it releases don't worry guys if you
don't want to see it I'm not gonna have
your opinion removed from the site
anyway make sure you comment below and
let me know I'll be doing my full usual
and explained breakdown of the movie so
keep your eyes peeled for that and if
you enjoyed this video then please like
it and make sure you check out my full
breakdown of everything that you need to
know about the scrolls which will be
linked at the end this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]